je m'engage à faire la revue
systématique de tout le stock de
réglementation française issue du cadre
agricole européen dans les six prochains
premiers mois de mon quinquennat c'est à
dire avant la fin de l'année 2022 et je
veux que l'agriculture soit la première
bénéficiaire de ce choc de
simplification j'ai parlé d'un comité de
la hache qui viendra simplifier les
normes pour toute l'industrie pour toute
l'économie française mais je veux vous
libérer de la sueur administration qui
vous étouffe depuis trop longtemps et je
veux faire en sorte que le travail des
agriculteurs et des agricultrices soit
mieux valoriser je baisserais les
charges qui pèsent sur la production
j'augmenterais de 20 à 50 % l'abattement
forfaitaire sur les terres agricoles
dans le calcul de la taxe sur le foncier
non bâti et l'augmentation que je
souhaite passera aussi par la réduction
des cotisations vieillesse gelé
baisserait d'un tiers dès l'été 2022 et
enfin je pérenniserait l'allègement des
charges patronales todt pour les
employeurs et les travailleurs
saisonniers et comme l'apprentissage et
clé j'exagère est totalement de charges
patronales les entreprises de moins de
dix salariés qui prennent un jeune en
apprentissage